russia's ruthless invasion of ukraine
continues
civilians are relentlessly attacked
including in schools apartment buildings
and hospitals and maternity homes
and despite repeated offers by the
ukrainian side russia has not shown any
willingness to seriously engage so far
negotiation for a diplomatic solution
instead all we hear are new lies and
false accusations and cynically
humanitarian corridors are either still
not opened
or being bombed by russian forces
shortly after they have been announced
so today we the european union and our
partner in the g7
continue to work in lockstep
to ramp up the economic pressure against
the kremlin
the three sweeping ways of sanctions we
have adopted
as well as the extension of their scope
this week
have hit russia's economy hard
the ruble has plummeted
many key russian banks are cut off from
the international banking system
companies are leaving the country one
after another
not wanting to have their brands
associated with a murderous regime
tomorrow we will take a fourth package
of measures to further isolate russia
and drain the resources it uses to
finance this barbaric war
first
this package contains that we will deny
russia the status of most favored nation
in our markets
this will revoke important benefits that
russia enjoys as a wto member
russian companies will no longer receive
privileged treatment in our economies
we will also work to suspend russia's
membership rights in leading
multilateral financial institutions
including the international monetary
fund and the world bank
we will ensure that russia cannot obtain
financing loans or any other benefits
from these institutions
because russia cannot grossly violate
international law
and at the same time expect to benefit
from the privileges
of being part of the international
economic order
second
we will continue pressuring russia
russia's elite close to putin as well as
their families and their enablers
and this is why g7 finance justice and
home affairs ministers
will meet next week
to coordinate the task force we set up
targeting putin's cronies
third
we're making sure that russian state and
its elite
cannot use crypto assets to circumvent
the sanctions
we will stop the group close to putin
and the architects of the war
from using these assets to grow and
transfer their wealth
fourth
we will ban the export of any eu luxury
goods from our countries to russia
as a direct blow to the russian elite
those who sustain putin's war machine
should no longer be able to enjoy their
lavish lifestyle
while bombs fall on innocent people in
ukraine
fifth
very importantly
we will prohibit the import of key goods
in the iron and steel factor from sector
from russian federation
this will hit a central sector of russia
system
the private of billions of export
revenues
and it will ensure that our citizens are
not subsidizing putin's war
and finally
we will propose a big ban on new
european investments across russia's
energy sector
because we should not be feeding the
energy dependency which we want to leave
behind us this ban will cover all
investments technology transfers
financial services you name it
for energy exploration and production
and thus have a big impact on putin
the european union stands firmly with
the brave people of ukraine
this is why we just this morning
disembers 300 million euros in emergency
macro financial assistance to support
ukraine's finances
this is the first tranche of 1.2 billion
euro financial aid package
and more will follow
this crisis is unprecedented
and so is the unity and speed of
reaction our democracies have shown so
far
you have heard me say this before and i
firmly repeat it
ukraine will prevail